European Union Finance and economy
ministers will discuss new rules aimed
at pre-empting bank crises and dealing
with problems like insolvency when they
happen at the next council in Brussels
the rules would require banks and
investment firms to draw up recovery
plans laying out the measures they would
take to restore their financial health
if things turn sour relevant authorities
would also have to prepare plans for
making a bank in trouble solvable again
the measures part of broader EU plans to
set up a banking union would establish
the order in which investors would help
bail out an institution and strife the
aim is to limit the use of taxpayer
money ministers will also work on
strengthening EU rules for taxes on
savings income the plans to make it
possible to tax all kinds of savings
income and products that generate
interest as well as to make it harder to
get around the regulations in place
currently member states are required to
exchange information so that interest
payments on savings made in one country
to people who live in another can be
taxed under the laws in the state of
residency the rules currently apply to
individual savers not companies the
ministers are likely to adopt a mandate
for negotiating strengthened savings tax
agreements with third countries like
Switzerland Liechtenstein and Monaco
they'll also pledge to step up the fight
against tax evasion and tax fraud and to
promote good practices and tax
governance in countries outside the EU